mentioned a few times in the podcast
about the state of your teeth or lack
thereof
well i'm 20 years old 28 years old and i
recently
my molars have been in a lot of pain i'm
just hoping it is just my wisdom teeth
growing in but i'm afraid i could be
something serious according to webmd i
have mouth care and
mouth cancer anyways i haven't been uh
to a dentist in close to a decade i
think i've developed some sort of phobia
of actually going to one especially
during times like this
what do you think maybe you can hit me
with some pros and cons about having
less teeth than that
you got to go to the dentist because
it's not it's not as if my teeth were
pulled
out by myself the teeth that i don't
have
were pulled off by dentists yeah they
assessed my mouth and when they went
their first reaction is ah
what you know what i mean and then they
have to go into another room and
you know i mean look at my teeth and
they laugh or they you know i mean they
laugh
or they or they shake their head like i
can't believe it got this bad right
and they have to come in and they
[ __ ] pull them out i've had all my
teeth
professionally pulled and assessed right
and i don't have teeth
the good news is if i don't think it's
cancer and the good news is that
you can chew with your gums
there's the pro i'll tell you i'll tell
you why i'll tell you why there's the
pro right
i've been chewing with my gums for the
last 10 years
meat i'm talking about meat man i really
want you guys to see how long it takes
for him to
it takes a while it takes he's there he
seriously eats takes him three hours on
a steak yeah yeah isn't that good for
you though today
yeah yeah it helps with the diet it just
like waits for the salivary enzymes to
like
melt the meat yeah very cool yeah but
you can chew with your gums right you
can chew with your tongue and the roof
of your mouth
the hard palate yeah right you can chew
or you could just swallow things whole
you can true
to with your front teeth which i do
right with nuts and opening up uh
sunflower seeds you know but i've chewed
um
hard candy with my gums oh my god
yeah yeah i've chewed and and my
teeth you do taste blood a lot
you know a lot you incorporate it with
with the flavors you know oh okay
of what you're eating flavor melting
yeah
yeah yeah and um i wish i had back teeth
it'd be much easier
but you know i can still get it in oh
good job you know
so um yeah go see a dentist because we
don't
also does he have mouth cancer just from
going on webmd wait i'm not
a dentist and i'm not a doctor yeah look
what you're wearing
you're a sith lord look i'm a authority
you have all the information so when i
first came
um to america i had just taken my braces
off
and so when i came to america i had
retainers and i don't know if you guys
have ever had braces
but um it kind of [ __ ] with your gums a
little bit so i had
really swollen overgrown gums
and my retainer like part of my retainer
was even on my gum that's how much gums
i had my teeth
my tooth to gum ratio was horrible and
to the point where i had to get most of
my gums
like cut out at when i was 15.
and then um on top of that my
con artist dentists put fillings like
these silver dark fillings yeah
all over my back teeth
because he said he wanted to build
insurance even though i have never had a
single cavity in like my whole life
wow it's crazy my dentist now about that
my dentist she's never had a cavity in
her life and i'll tell you why
i've never had a cavity in my life
because
my mom and my aunts and everyone in the
philippines all my mom just is the only
one of ten children who doesn't have
false teeth everyone has postiso
everyone in the philippines that i know
even like the my cousins my age
they all have false teeth so i know that
inherently i don't have good teeth
genetics yeah
so what i made sure of was i
took all the measures i see a dentist
every six months i get a cleaning every
six months i get an x-ray once a year
i floss i just take care of my
my mouth real well because i know that i
don't have i have a predisposition
to bad teeth i've never have a i've
never had a tooth that hasn't had a
cavity
really yeah even though your front teeth
have never had them they've oh they've
all had it
not doubt it you need to drink more
water
that's what you keep saying i think
that's like i drink some
yeah so to this person i say absolutely
you need to go to a dentist and
like at least my dentist their covid
measures are
so strict and tight they only have like
two people in that entire place
for like a whole hour so please go see a
dentist
i i also just like i really really hate
bad breath so like
yeah just please please go see a dentist
is my bad breath bad uh no because
you don't have yeah your breath is
actually it's bad when
here's what i hate i hate smokers breath
in the morning it smells like
actual dung like it smells like
like um toe jam
and [ __ ] and like [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
and i don't like so that's why i don't
like about smokers
a morning breath but beyond that it's
you're okay you have
good saliva i think enjoy it strong
enzymes there